I was the oldest thumps of [__] I never
felt a part in your family adaiah be
bitten off another 16 years olds on that
never-ending cycle gone to prison
institutions near-death experiences and
I got invited on a Clemont backpacker
already to Thailand a box for England
logic it I'll go to the box in silence
he said don't get in the ring with these
Chinese girl pretty lips why I have five
fights literally every night
I was late 84 transport you don't work
loads of pain emotionally going on
physically you can see conscious all day
long and you know what doesn't bother me
but don't break out bumpers and bumps a
big help night coach please and
sentences pain misery and a launcher and
that's what I am that she jumped on a
fight the live other friend [__] off
the bay and Porsche analyzed pure head
of him focus and I got arrested Fernanda
on a stolen mobile phone and this is
what I was using like the phone for
eternal deals with mr. mayor
within a week of being in a pigeon in
Bangkok and it was the most frightening
experience and the screams every scree
was falling deeper you know about this
stuff but you never actually you know I
did saw my said when you [__] then they
pin you down and then they pin another
guy to the wall and they rape them and
make you watch it I mean how do you get
almost I just buried me other dog she
should hash and he feeling any force you
know you couldn't invent or conjure it
up new Asian amazed what you can witness
not be in shops attitude
[Music]
this week on the true Geordi podcasts
are you taking my foot lastly we've got
Billy Moore on the show welcome Billy
Mia thanks yeah thanks for having me
absolutely love the movie about your
life and our society we have to get this
guy this is I mean I've never seen
anything like while I was watching on a
prayer before dawn it's available on
every Isabel on Amazon Prime I watch on
Amazon you watched on Sky so it's
readily available it just hits you so
quick and so hard and then like Lawrence
is a expert in this or so but it shots
or while it looks at me as a it's
probably one of the most since like a
Fight Club or something like that it's
one of the most intense fight yes I've
ever seen yeah it's a lot of films sort
of like to obviously get you on review a
film you're not in it is based on you
but a lot of films you don't feel like
you're in it you feel like you're
watching a fight and in this film you
could feel every punch game wasn't as
amazing yeah the dialect is quite clever
but in that area yeah what was it like
for you to UM to watch your back or to
be part of the process and it must have
been a bit unusual to watch them telling
your story
yeah well affair sama was that between
Cannes Film Festival in 2017 that was a
him you know I felt really out of place
and it sucked she's on a red carpet you
know definitely yeah but when they we
went into the shin of it it was mash if
it's like the biggest [__] omen in your
it would shoot a half thousand people in
it all dressed you know what struck she
goes and shoots and really smart and you
know next thing this this movie comes on
the screen with the young actor playing
you know Joe Cole playing me shelf and
no force to I was high for
personally concert experienced eight and
I knew what was coming
I started by thinking that the audience
we're gonna get really feds often what I
mean because I had kind of been around a
trope
at the end of it no Diosdado but I was
like an eight and a half minute like
standing there was a standing ovation
for the in a half minutes and I said sir
James
Shamus from a medicine Yves the guy you
finance the movie I said is this normal
he went look within France these are the
ashes clear
she'll ever come across if he didn't
like it to be you whether really it or
not know you love it
aim and then the reviews the next day
because that's what you get Dona you can
review stays away from all the national
newspapers you never look at all five
stars and it was like wow it was quite
powerful but to watch him I think
freaked me out
really there because you're like brought
everything sort of shellfish oh yeah no
the reality of it because you had a big
part to play in the script and I wanted
it to be as authentic and as transparent
you know was possible it didn't want it
to be like maze or pause I a massage
we worked alongside a Jonathan aah being
wrote the script and when it came to
fruition it was like it was just it was
just perfect you know I was wondering I
was young and knowing I was gonna meet
you in person how close it was to the
reality and the fact that you seen it
brought back so many memories obviously
was for me what I loved about the movie
is it didn't oversell things I've been
through some traumatic things and you
think of how you can how you would
recreate those things and naturally
people do like like wolf of Wall Street
no that was hugely AG dog yeah but with
this guy this character played by Joe
Cole he doesn't overdo it he's not
explaining what he's thinking the whole
time you know it it gives the audience
credit you're intelligent enough to get
what's going on you know you don't need
all the backstory you don't need you can
weigh it off as it's going on and that's
very unusual I think because I you know
people just mean the rocks the biggest
movie star everything's dum-dum doesn't
yeah you don't really basic challenge
the audience to get it without needing
everything laid out for them also a lot
of the telling comes through how
visceral it is like how intense the
whole thing is how its shot you actually
feel like you're part of it okay you
know normally you're watching something
with this it felt like you're actually
experiencing it it must be really weird
for you having gone through it and like
not having like a pts are a PTSD sort of
thing but bringing those memories back
without formally the people we don't get
PTSD right yeah no certainly Zoo
especially I wouldn't tell her
what a Liverpool soldier of the show for
every father's needs as well yes just
it's just like it's kind of like the
environment you bros open another I
think I was quite lucky in a sense you
know I don't know he in a way a GP blows
up you know in Liverpool and Mapuche
garden in the south end [__] baby see
so Sox this way we see on the board that
it was crazy him quite difficult songs I
always felt shepherded siblings in a
long run I was the oldest types of Shh
you know I was like I never felt a part
in your family
it's was strange I always felt like it
was an object you know and people have
been knocking at the door for me
brothers and my sisters and I couldn't
understand that they couldn't put a
finger on it grown up feeling really
isolated and I think that's walked out
and said into every relationship I ever
kind of I just drifted in and out of
toxic relationships through all my life
I'm just like you know this is why a
Pharma shell finish these unsavory
places we much of a ladies man growing
up nas definitely not diet be bitten
often of a 16 years old in over the box
of Easter eggs well this is it this is
the what kind of Easter eggs
till they cavities there must have been
good Sammy worth it I was it wasn't even
about the Easter eggs it was just the
principal but it was liked by him by a
guy passed away in now him it was young
kid he was a it's just kind of demanded
the stuff that we'd stolen out of this
car years ago when I am we shed not
let's share this fairly yeah you know
and he didn't want to do it that way and
it's just ended up me sandal off finish
shelf and you know everyone backing down
and you know unfortunately you know we
got me in a corner me go piss off so if
I wasn't a ladies man by any stretch
naturally obviously it's painful but is
can you remember exactly what that felt
like
yeah I remember exactly what I was
wearing what I was doing and everything
about it because yeah you know being
blatant this story is I've got a next
book out what she's getting
hopefully published by the end of next
month and I kind of brought a lot of
stuff from Machado
into this one mmm so what kinda reflect
and not start at that I remember I was
tripping I saw had an MBS my body in
show we were out we were crafting there
was a few visual things that we you
should not be doing but we did that
anyway this is what we did when we were
kids we didn't have a we didn't know any
better
no use justify that I mean mom said
don't go out and get caught stealing
cars she never said don't go out and
steal cars
sorting just a fire and then you know
him the feeling I went for it was like
it was I didn't feel like getting bit
off you know it was quite it was quickly
here Norman mm-hmm but what it did do is
I picked it up and the guy fled and you
know a few me friends go oh my god
Judy's on the floor I had to ski shoes
on right back in the 80s they sports by
the way like probably in the show-me
shizzle I am at this ski shoes so I'm a
dog fancy zipper unzips and he said just
put it in your pocket
the ambulance is on its way so it's
either put it in one of these ships and
the ambulance says openly when same okay
so where's your yeah and I was like him
it was like a nightmare tryna find it so
about seven eight minutes before the
poles are out with a bit of fluff on it
and he stuck it in this gel bag and then
he shot me sure wish the hospital and
the I see him Michael che asleep in the
tears he stays away to stitch this year
back on and he did he stood back on it
was stuck I can't remember but could you
imagine lying on a bed right straighten
your box off while getting your ear
staged on the force and they were going
through my mind that they were really
really uninvited not I mean it was all
the lights were going everywhere I was
getting it stitched on and then an ended
name I went all mad a big bandage Swamy
mom and I had to go back and I kind of
members I think the speech is shortened
ladies at and it was black I look like a
quaver oh well it clearly yeah sure it
was done and I didn't well the tunnel I
didn't want to lose you you know for the
freedom Shh that's it reach period the
Canada God [__] douche me NOLA and
it's off that was happening from behind
is your Emily Sanchez D
fourth off the gas dish no this is like
that what I was thinking this is the way
I was thinking if I guess it you know we
leave it on yeah he said he hadn't even
stopped it and yeah you know I was
changed to a name that was yeah he has
to take it back off again and then what
and then that was you
I've got like half a satellite and I
kind of struggled with me shellfish the
imminent bills and relationships with
the girls so I had this image then which
was an ID law yeah very good half a year
you know you got a face like you pimp
it's being punched in know when it
became a coping mechanism for me because
I remember my mom changed me years ago
what's you want for christmas i was only
shitty Shevin another weights weights
for don't you wanna like a Star Wars
Millennium Falcon or IBM action I was
like no weights she asked me why and I
said because I wanted a protector
because it was to get him bullied by his
out the years I mean it was difficult
and I was really skinny a little knobbly
knees you had freckles you know I was
getting called [__] splashing school
that was me in his name
[__] [__] splash cornflakes and [__]
splash Wow
I used to call me mum [__] these are the
shanab you see before half [__] splash
sure that's not unusual though in
Liverpool for kids to have freckles and
knobbly knees because I remember when I
used to go visit my grandmother was a
kid with freckles and not only knees
next door to me and he was a hard kid
there's something about knobbly knees in
my yard so do you work do you think you
were bullied or do you think you were I
was bullied because you know we were
poor in a sense we are there no no we
never wore Fallis rouses or been
chairman shirts we've got governments
formed with clobber and it was like you
knew it yeah little mean you knew it a
name and everyone knows it
everyone knows you kids are clear as
well so go it's funny but in the rough
area I mean I grew up on a council
estate as well it's weird but because
none ears are God knows it's really a
parent who has anything almost like so
like what trainers you're wearing when I
was a kid was massively if you had an
egg trainers like it didn't matter
everything else your when was [__] you
had night trainers that means you're
you're safe that normally
and Liverpool was a bit of especially in
the 80s it was actually like the place
where people wanted to dress
yeah like nice because Liverpool fans
and I guess not over defense but
Liverpool fans were going around Europe
you know find a new fashion out and sort
of bring him back all these like you say
you were wearing the zipper see that was
like bit unfashionable yeah yeah you
couldn't be Sheen's edvard and now
unless you were on the Alex book you
said that your dad especially was like a
figure of struggle for you and you
wanted to get big and strong so you
could protect your mom I mean I [__]
totally get that
coming from a single-parent family how
long was he in your life early on using
our lives what himself you know him me
mom kicked him out really this was I was
like I'm almost on autopilot Sam
really I was shakes of his shoulder I
think me more father typicals have a Sam
managed but you know even in being a was
he wasn't any benefit to the households
he was more of a you know a big drinker
very controlling fix audience at Long's
a better shake shake lock up nice
remember him I used to hate that the end
shoot [__] to Shepard shows him oh my
god
can't even remember - no but it was
fourth inaudible yeah because I knew was
I've talked about States after it really
crossroads all right yeah I was only
vivid yeah I remember rerun Dallas roads
than anybody you still was Abed after
that but it was there was a lot of name
violence and sure I was shifted to
getting beaten Allah to him I don't know
why well shouldn't you know I just kind
of always wanted meat as approval ones
of those loved ones of his ascension
one of them was just say kind of telling
me that he loved me which was really
really difficult and you know he was a
boxer that's never seen a fight hmm
police told me of these great stories of
when he was pissed about all these these
these fights see that so join the boxing
club yeah open Eid show me some some
Ascension and all he said-she on the
boxing club and he said and briefly and
it was nice but
then I started to build my own
confidence in my own self esteem and I
didn't need him in me life when was that
like when you want your early teens are
sort of that stable sweet by 14 and 16
yeah he start to grow away closer don't
you yeah from the from the ages of 40
and 60 and it was like you know I'm on
my own here
I don't really need you and that's the
reality that was already going on you
just became more aware of it then oh
yeah you were like yeah you're on it dad
yeah you know I mean so you you took
these skills ironically they basically
were everything when you were in that
Thai prison by the looks of it and yeah
became a massive part of keeping
yourself alive yeah you know I mean what
you learned in that Boxing Club Gordon
to the prison can I can ask one question
before we go into the prison bit alright
because that the mood so the movie
starts just to lay out for people
haven't seen the movie starts very
quickly and basically on Joe Cole not
the footballer although he be excellent
doing drugs and living a lifestyle which
isn't particularly it's not much self
loving it's basically a drug-fueled
lifestyle out in Thailand right and so
the police burst in and obviously arrest
you how I kind of want to know how we
got to that point away you end up in
Thailand where you because it's not a
usual thing to go halfway around the
world and do that and know the story and
he always share this because it's it was
quite significant see me later now there
was a big massive changing in the way I
lived it started on a collision blue
from Balkan prison in 2003 and him it
was on that never-ending cycle haunted
prison institutions near-death
experiences [__] inside of being [__]
inside feds overall a not normal it was
a way I didn't want to use drugs knew
that was shortly shabby that settled
[__] this mother's an ocean off but not
known what to do and my answer was our
clam on the roof and I remember like it
was the austere stay the yeah we were on
the ad and was about so on the inmates
house and I went down the whispers no
now we're gonna stay out for a [__]
house what I mean when I gone back he
and it's too hot it's [__] hot in
there no one's going back in you
yeah yeah yeah and then at Ashley's
let's get on the roof like for that was
recreate sighs here you know how we are
we got up there Boucher was amazing
because the kids we had to get like
sheets thrown out the window we had to
get side means and knots
I said it's a rope get this kid called
Asti say climb up this training pipe
shimmy up it because it has a little
body around are we got always right
beyond me him and he reached it's awful
but when he got to the top the whole
prison just see Danielle with screams of
approval I mean the wind is my Bangor
head and he was up there like Rocky
Balboa I just looked over I just [__]
craved that attention I just wanted it I
wanted to be him up there getting all up
all in CS you know so two guys got home
that it was my sin you know I was the
oldest I was a little bit overweight by
this stage I've been on antidepressants
for a few weeks and you know I was
taking any care that or he get old off
but it didn't want to carry on continue
chose Ashley up and I remember this crew
call mr. muscle and he shouted
you'll never get up there you fat ass
watch it yeah come on and I fell off the
roof about lobster roof off halfway up
and landed right on the Coxes in the ash
angel my saw and the shame I was filled
with like motivated me said psycho again
because it didn't want to get like just
didn't want off them feelings get him in
and it's saying this was all a turn-off
she'd ask you what the guys at the top
of the rally pull me off cause a dubose
well it gets to the soft uh and I guess
the change rehabilitation there you got
this year's the yells there's screams
couldn't amaze it and then it went
silent it was over I know it was about
the guy getting up next mm not afford
what the for covers on and I wanted you
know seriously concert please and I was
just jumping off because envision as me
shelf get him for whom like being and
taking Zhanna block and you know spend
them right there they got chickens on
the Block in the shed occasion unit
and this is what changed me like this is
the question I was like I'm in 8 a.m.
I'm in a shell occation unit and I'm Lee
and leads on an 8 mile on a lock which
is come off a roof in Liverpool through
60 individual teach paste all over the U
K I'm gonna shell and the guy next door
to me asked me for the Latham Annie but
a Sam had got a light soon I match few
one of the cleaners he'd killed himself
you know we don't go himself and he was
a young lad named kind of it saw a woman
and I was [__] Michelle on I was
crying and I was troubling to me pillar
but I was always open and I was acting
so often you know put on a brave face
and I remember shootings Ireland and I'm
wondering what I need this is uniform
Iman my Malamud me mommy's boy buy any
you know I don't really speak to me mom
and she Amy feelings and we don't have
feelings we're become phenomenally me
mom she was open the door to the phone
Swagger's house know that image that
mask be mom picked up the phone I
thought a couple of rings and she's like
the loft that came out of her voice
shoes or your location what's going on
and I couldn't even answer no as a
lumping we froze at Sears well I'm not
my eyes at these two big screws and the
next minute of force if they see me
right here breaking down breaking down
and I it'll be a weakness and they'll
judge me and I you know I mask you let
me see that male musk you let me see
that weak little bit worse possible
point lawyers and in it yeah I've
watched a lot of [__] prison shows
and you show any weakness and that's it
like yeah so that was what I didn't want
to show any weakness and I went back to
that show you know only mom says I mean
she knew never has to say you not and
she's you spend and all you're in
because it couldn't actually yeah I was
gonna know you're there and you're gonna
have to Shane on she is Shawn she's nice
fellow
that was the first time anyone but
probably people have told me for years
again I'll raise but that was the first
time it sunk in there was up to that
window of opportunity to you its
audience in me a thermos for I went back
to shell shops and then I wrote this
letter said this probation officer said
welcome it can you can you can can you
can you help me and he got me into a
rehabilitation
drug rehabilitation in Bristol
transitions on it he says you know we
where'd you want to go I said I want one
with women you know what did you tell
Shelly result you know poor transitions
on me on car the recovery Megan I fancy
yeah south of France yeah yeah we're so
this is you know you won't help put your
[__] good help yeah yeah benefits
really you know you forget that you've
just been like jagger ization as
expiration is just pure loneliness for
years
and you're in prison onion emulation
wrong yeah and in a position yet again
what a meaningful for doing wrong a name
this issues like the castle Israeli it
was in I was in I found I understand
them a some awareness around me through
huge you know I got clean and then I got
invited on a three-month back
pathologies to Thailand which attendant
said it's it's it's five years you know
but when I was out there you know I'm a
world-class car caddy and pleasure
sheikah you know I'll [__] squeeze me
shelf into a tight pair of onesies just
to get a feeling it's just like that
just wanted to change the way I felt you
know and I mean loads of different
people and at six I and it's tropical
I've never been I've never left
Liverpool unless it was on a sweatbox so
I'm gonna what a flight now in silent I
mean must be quite exciting Walsh it was
a [__] major and I loved it the food
is [__] abortion and the women were like
I love you what your name and I was it
you know I just felt like a superstar
aim yeah cuz you're obviously walk
around will you quite muscular good time
yeah yeah I was young muscular double
Jim of shingle no kid said no - no there
was not loading me back I was free you
know we may said they about Oxford
England I was a kid you know that's
pretty I achieved kind of clinician
names kind of areas and I got to the box
in silent he said don't get in the ring
with these challenged or break he lives
within minutes and I'm I saw that yet
shot and I got in the ring I'm a few
lives broken you know knee and shallots
you repeating ash a mistake and
expecting different results was a do it
again and then do it again but every Sam
it I got back he and Elaine something
new you know I'm not one of those people
just out
I'm going to get back in and uh and so i
excels and i sports you to the fact that
he had skills with me ants you know a
lance it's a flow kicks and knees and
elbows was my toy that was my name you
know he went back home but the day
before he said well would off when I'm
staying I'm gonna lay in a new language
adopt a new cult unum stay here we're in
Thailand Chiang Mai and so is that quite
a big city or is it a smaller it's like
the second biggest shitty and silent
you've got Bangkok and in Chiang Mai
didn't the Tutsis not hang them sticks a
table no no you're not a big built-up
city of it yeah massive but it's big and
although did you afford to live I was
boxing for tips aim whoa I was boxing
for tips I have a job teaching English
because he had a TEFL that I had studied
for teaching English as a foreign
language all got a job in a name and as
you can have a little big school with
fifty kids
does that mean there's a little tyke it
yeah I [__] right I got a shock in
the end all these Tigers was what I was
like he was like a well in Sioux hear me
fear so I cs50 students that's [__] yeah
shameless a on you I look like John she
imagined as well they're your those kids
and you walk in they must have been like
what the hell I just felt like I felt
like a fraud even though I had a snaffle
and I could see see English you know I
didn't want to teach them and I was just
it was scouts in a sense what I mean and
you know now then what's happenin and
you know just to entertain but you know
I did do me best and show me is that
it's right but I wasn't
it wasn't for me it was just a means to
an answer pay the bills a box lovely
even and I got its job Sylvester so long
stone stands in on Rambo which
unbelievable by the way I've read this
about you I was reading you're like I'm
like [__] stood double as a rumble
yeah like of all that you've had a hard
life already but thrown that in there
some people just go some people just
have that as a story yeah yeah
that's enough to get on the bus they go
in there they go to dinner parties and
they don't tell the rest the story they
just go I was a Rambo stunt double
that's enough Senate passport thought
really good David woman what the [__]
was that light like meetin Sylvester
Stallone and do it not with him and was
he impressed with how much you look like
him no because it didn't look like him
it was just stands in yes all right
okay it was yeah he's yeah the stunts or
blips a Polish guy and quite quite quite
really laid resemble them I was your
name I was gonna see em sayin and I met
this guy on a machine and he looked
familiar
I couldn't pitch you I couldn't like
pitchy where that seen him his lips fill
up in a row now this was yeah this was a
guy from England not Madison the
username I'm sorry I know it's a bishop
is a young guy and he said their City
are you one of the boxers push no I was
in a circle at the Sam maybe normal you
know so you look familiar when someone
caught a nation sleaze you made sushi me
my name is Mike Myers and I didn't watch
Scotty but he did kind of look familiar
and he explained why he was in Cylons
and they were making ground but when I
got really excited about you know all
the past and then a couple of days later
the cast and crew come in taking like
asking you know non sighs all the
Westerners did there wasn't many
visionary shaking our non vision taking
pictures and you know would be the
ancestor name to be an axis and I said
yeah yeah so to give me a call
a week later and of course it was a
whines oh hey Billy we like you to be
Sylvester Stallone stunt standing can
you do that I was like before who's dish
what it was he
Jimmy Dean stands in looking on like him
no man he's just need a stand-in this is
that I his understandings got the shits
man he had the green curry and he got
the shits I'm sold
I went on share so I was like thinking
this is a blogger when I'm s they don't
roll off his old cell in Chiangmai I
went there it was 5:00 a.m. effort to
get me out of four competitors gotta be
a block dish gets there and at the end
all the cast gets me in this little mini
boss and shakes me see am dis jungle and
and there he was strong just walked by
any other presence she initially advice
I've never felt long like here like I'm
not like one of size to put
fine Wow I could walk watching rocky
yeah he was my it was my hair oh yeah no
he was really rocky bail board and Rambo
and I just thought throughout the
opportunity city on [__] be a party unit
one with him was amazing and I ended up
in a jam I ended up pounding on speed
ethics chases I was quite likeable I
think because he brought me in to him
and he would've loved the fact that you
were actual fighter yeah he says you
must be fight sunny aim he said yeah man
is a warrior cuz Kevin king is just
sculpture and I used to say is his
position his product manager he
accidently self-made millionaire he went
today la and and got lucky with salon
and Westwood everybody at work yes
yeah well Joe's father boys get all the
shoes but yeah it was it that was like
that was amazing I was on you know one
with him fill him for a little while and
got to chat with him and spend a bit of
time with him
you didn't speak watch boy knows you
gentleman he was never doubt of Kalat
that as well yeah that's because he's
not actually an actor no he's just a man
who plays very versatile oh yeah yeah
yeah you know and I remember he asked
for the volunteer because he was gonna
rip this baby's soldiers windpipe up
with his bare hands and he wants to play
to the light and the camera and all a
certain you know the guy at Dawlish
this stuff yeah so I saw stands in and
he's got a son he froze and I was like
okay and I was he Kevin I said nah no
one can actually [__] rip someone's
windpipe off with the bare hands and he
bent round ball cap [__] great so yet
that was that was an experience as well
you know what you talk about the the
movie star thing like I would totally be
starstruck by Sylvester yeah I'm
imagining is you on set and him go no
need a volunteer and you're like
straight away yeah me I'll burn off and
then as he's doing it you're just going
there's movie stars and then this
Sylvester Stallone is a legend
yes family is really there quite an
interesting but the rocky story the fact
that he went and he wrote that himself
in the real like now like will want the
script offer you all these production
companies when it will take the script
but we're gonna get someone who like is
an actual after a plate exec na na you
only get this if I clearly yeah he
forced his way I look at that then mate
like that made Matt Damon Ben Affleck
did the same thing inspired by him so
he's like made a generation of people in
many ways he was like the guy who
inspired that that YouTube kind of feel
where it's like you're gonna make your
own thing you're gonna star in it it's
kinda mad how him in like our knees are
like best mates now they're all on each
other's Instagram they hung out with
each other like daily oh they're in the
Expendables or whatever it was but
Sylvester's of male Expendables but
already came in Wow so anyway I mean
yeah we're telling his story now so then
you made that money but you were still
boxing how did you then you were you
doing drugs and box at the same time or
did you reality what happened was I was
I was I was in recovery it was clean I
was abstinence I stopped taking drugs
you know him and then I started meeting
people you know on the stance of meeting
girls and I didn't understand you know
the affairs of the art and the emotional
upheaval the rejection you know I mean
it was easy when you don't the roads you
can just walk on such mission she's a
lesbian
that was my sure that's the way it was
your name you know I met this scale and
our relationship was based on a
dictionary I found how she was with
another guy and you know because she
wasn't answered on a phone and you know
she was gone missing at the weekends and
it fell deeply in love and she was not
bad girls you had to beat Schieffelin
she was amazing and she couldn't speak a
word of English
and I found out she was Jim and she was
she was with a guy Nellie gonna play
come I come I make tomato my misspent
why cuz that's all I could focus a why
why why why and then she knows in broken
English in the best bloke of English
that she couldn't more stairs I do love
you seen seen him no problem obviously
put the dish in England this mean you
end of not
you and your Fallon I'm silent explain
because their culture was solely
difference in any way it broke behind
you put me out and I remember the pain I
was feeling I was clean at the time as
well I was honorable with the pain and
no matter how many times we got in the
ring you know you could put a plaster on
a course and you could you could mend
the broken eyeball a he couldn't put a
plaster on a broken I had what I mean
and it was like him unless it was
another disaster that was in Waiting did
you go and fight more after that were
you like so rage and you oh yes get me
in the ring yeah it was just more f5
fights
Leslie every nice nice show fights most
of them listen I swear I remember that
the young shy guy Stephen in a show face
Whitney didn't wanna get nothing any I
want me to be like no you know say sure
fights do you mean like exhibition
exhibitions but even ever but you
weren't called 100 percent I'm as human
or was this all out tried to knock them
out issues all this with this dish was
damn a exhibition box and more moist and
we say oh and this was made can you even
do that going all out so you find that
hot dude long you find it how long you
in the ring for a night fine for like 3
roles so some that I was it was like it
was three rounds but it was they at the
lab of crayfish right I believe that was
quite physically your flight all out
every night like that that the men don't
think about this is obviously we now
have USA which is brought like noite I
like pop culture in the Western world
and it's like that is the worst form of
striking and you're doing it every night
yeah twelve rounds if you do it 12
rounds you he wasn't managing swells
easy I mean book with in threes
please to these but H because they'd
have to go in as well because they left
them plated so was like it's Horniman
every may lose the atoms like a soilless
every night further you get the more
money you just know it was just cheap
[__] was just you know it was never any
massive competitions how you fight
depends on so the more entertaining you
are yeah the morning's is changeable and
I was an asset because I could
communicate with the foreigners and I
sure to put myself on them as well see
look you get in the [__] link right
inside pay the bills the way we are that
I mean I'd make it about the kid means
the end it was my
was all she'll chances no I wanted short
look these [__] pork I'm [__]
skiing by the way right
I was chickens but I wasn't letting him
know I was making a rock damn she means
she got a family to feed
so what manipulate aim the the cloud was
Sherman yeah that was that that was yeah
and then your the Conor McGregor of that
well no he was the western guys yeah
that's where la most of me aim most of
me technique from no no camps no skills
not say anybody you know you've
regimental you routine and if you get
kicked in the [__] ribs you need
Celestine New York pill right and I was
like they couldn't speak English and I
couldn't speak sigh I was getting kicked
in the neck
kicked in the ribs kick to the back of
the leg decisive navels Gong sounds
about the for and I just watched on
objects on for yet all eyes lift that
knee up what I mean the scare the
announcer the girl avoid they're gonna
see if you they're gonna keep come up
with the knees they're gonna push you
the colossi logic get out of all i
analytically it's after I became a part
of what they drink gonna mean and it was
mine I'm in control of it your honor for
her near me because I've been a stormy
life and there's no one gonna put me
[__] down or more and that's what was
going through my mouth and then this
relationship and then I was thinking
[__] this makes no I mean I'm really
angry and he takes it sensing I was a
part in the film there that happens to
me all the time but I get really when I
get it you know it was full of rage and
talk about some the people that were
closest to me because these were friends
these really these gonna be like
comrades yeah comrades do a diet cup you
know because you're like you're like I'm
a team it's like the WWE at that time
wrestling type thing you're all mates
behind the scenes book you actually have
to beat the [__] out of each other as
well every night that's a bizarre
relationship Bob yeah it was your name
and it wasn't clean money it it one
little lets you down it's like know the
relationship and and yeah it's a shame
you know you [__] in a barbershop long
enough you're gonna end up with an air
hose you know I used to [__] in these
bars every night thinking water you
don't got loads of pain emotionally
going on physically you can take punches
all day long and you know it doesn't
bother me but when you know you're
getting you know then feelings of
the rejection the loss the longan the
loneliness you know a typical music
class who was that then it becomes a red
bull and then it becomes alpha whiskey
and you know I know cuz I've got a bit
of an understanding on three years clean
by this time and I've got this you
understand that I've I take that ring
that is gonna be an outcome there's
gonna be a consequence that I remember
for whom did that it was just a battle
with in conflict over long you know it
was a face it was [__] rarely rarely
adverse events risky and I don't even
like whiskey and I wanted a plan D but
it didn't shell it over there dish dish
dish won't cope with this way she and I
felt the pain and sensation going down
you know be floatin name and you know
fun allergic reaction to drugs you know
don't break out and open some pumps a
place out on Coach please and chances
just pain misery and loss and that's
what I am that just jumped on a bike
with a brother friend folks off the Bama
and Paul China white pure head of him I
don't go okay let's go to the bathroom
just enjoy your nights out and party and
I go home and sleep let's go to for
campaigning the golden triangle by some
element of focus for our lives out of
and that's what they're to come back and
then because the game is so strong I
wanted to be a little bit more what's
the cocaine you don't sell cocaine over
here we'll get your Yabba but the folks
that it's a it's crazy drug basically
that Yabba it's that's what the sun's
laser does which was methamphetamine and
we got this distro girl never [__]
seen never talked before and it's took
it to another level and I was like a
shoot your crack cocaine I give you a
12-hour shift but he's just like on fire
and I caught me in the ring even more I
was fighting even more I was angry at me
you know sounds of mind and clarity it
was gone long I started to get a little
bit more a [__] I got a drugs off
with the Thai guys and a name stands as
a shell and so so far all the foreigners
because of them did what they would you
shall you did so did to make ends meet
him just for me i but really that
develop irish Sam I was in a full-blown
relapse now it's not a few months before
I was arrested and then casually said
you know but I was for him not paranoid
you know you know he has a [__] shell
a fridge because it was every Savio was
a little bit was speaking to me in
Spanish follow me it was just me my
buddy this is a cocktail of disaster in
it because not only is the drugs like
you're probably getting brain damage on
a nightly basis at this point later you
know yeah there'd be a lot of
concussions in there that's about the
black eyes you know I got a beer me had
to be throbbing like a box of orange it
was quite you know there'll be black and
blue we get massages of these sideburns
every night so no [__] cuz it was
just [__] painful
yeah it was quite cheap so you basically
just stuck in a cycle yeah didn't and
you weren't conscious enough to get out
no mom I wasn't is where the movie picks
up really yeah I shoulda went home
should know I know that she's what
people Shango all but I have to shame
and then relapse I'm not selling me mum
not selling me family you're not selling
any friends you know just keep it at a
sheath Nick you know kept it like kept
me in it
you know what show it was one of the
worst things the shame is [__] it was
like Seamus Lee you know shouldn't be
shamed into silence that shame would
keep me silent nothing wrong with
failing no y'all saw like people are so
scared of failing because everyone else
ago you failed and say well this that's
right like we don't take anything it's
very hard to have that rude and also so
rarely happens that people if you do
admit failure or admit shame
most people don't point at you and go
you're a [__] idiot most and God
sorry about that let me hear about
extremists like you like people who are
always trying to be the best I heard
something you're your own biggest critic
I would assume as well definitely I was
aim and she's found I was I was I was
just a lot in this fantasy even be
friends we go on look bill you know get
back to reality I said this is reality
this is my [__] reality this is what
it is I was trying to convince me shelf
and manipulate me shelters I believe in
it but the but the but that the fact was
it was it was like how it was sold for
her nightmare you know he ended up it
was that skinny head angle eyes off her
[__] said he saw I'd lost all my
weight
at this police officer call P long that
means or whatever nice thing he was
using drugs with me right so the
corruption was four massive
I felt it was bulletproof or forces
could get away with anything you know
and then I gets arrested with a mobile
phone if you know that drugs in the
house I remember the arrest it was Jay
and I was one of the sigh boxes sadly
that cracks me up a bit surprised you in
the place came bursting through the
doors because I say bulletproof yeah it
was she I remember the call I I got a
call of Fame one of the young side boxes
you would beat on Showbox wrong but he's
[__] schlepping at the bestest amps
he's always you know yet his own agenda
him so you worked out that it was him
yeah no styrofoam you up any bands
believe no I've got your trainees in me
talk so when I an opening them neither
and I was just walk walk at this time so
it's not officially but I share them in
xuxian apartments and I put the phones
out and at least a billion more than ten
minutes to shop and as it lay back a
fault
that's all really not so much Nagle and
I mean and I knew they said for me or be
offering to bring them now he's never
done a [__] thing for me no I mean why
would he do it much I got up went to the
door and I seen four and please bring up
the stairs and you do a page he stays
away no you ain't do it they were
playing clothes but I just knew I mean I
looked at an idea that I had a call 45
on the on the bed stand and a load of
drugs losses high Stinkweeds Losey yeah
but tablets and that would be fish but I
gotta see there's no [__] window you
know it means the floor what I was off
plugs all and just stuck there out of me
because plug in slightly of my back
passage him that's that's way that's one
of the first things you see in the movie
I was like holy [__] this guy it's just
like that scene in the movie is just how
it was it was great the way John Stefan
that I like to go obviously we spoke
about that scene cause it was it was
paramount to the you know the arrest
you know and then the incarceration you
know and then the trucks sneaking on I
remembered like getting them up then
this definer going the combat mission
because it was a new corn and a weapons
lab mission and then he had a few phones
lying around and then I'm wondering
about this corn we're gonna get a long
time and I realized that you know it
wasn't really that important because
usually non-stop sort of gone over in
silence what I mean and I got arrested
for handle on a stolen mobile phone and
this is what I was using like the phone
for with photography so it was like
changing the phone cuz my pattern right
yeah the shame which I was buying phones
and you know I got caught with a few
name I've got three years three years
for a stolen mobile own yeah I don't
know smells awful so that's benefit yeah
yeah you see you've got the prison in
the movie and then like [__] into drugs
how [__] painfully yeah it wasn't but
what I was really struck by in that
first scene when you're arrested is your
level of like resistance and resilience
mmm
I think a lot of people would just sort
of be like go down stay quiet and you
know just a bit more subservient the
whole way through this film the way they
portray you which earned a lot of
respect from my cybers you're constantly
pushing back you're surrounded in a cell
by all those guys you're pushing them
back the police are trying to arrest you
you push them and there's no fear
there's there's fear there but it's like
you also seem to be well aware of the
fact that if you show too much weakness
you're going to be a victim you driven
the Shonda strongly did this wrong
propelling yeah it's a so a place of
like I'm not gonna [__] take this
[__] at so homie life from anyone I've
stopped taking that and I'm not gonna
continue you know taking it again from
anyone so it was it got to a point where
I didn't want to get arrested because it
didn't want to do with throttle
simple so off resist but I mean I went
to the police and I didn't want to get
in same as ease and saw what to do
because I get walked all over you know
on our first experience you go on and
Michelle was a [__] nightmare I mean I
remember walking pity they call an
incident into the prison my name [__]
ends on around the one place with the
boats officers are not to charge you
know british circulation and this shoot
that you
couldn't even identify stunk what did it
taste like oh it's really [__] more
like like like sweaty fish it was like
you know them catfish that the chopped
open it was like all kinds of bits of
whatever I remember port of spirit early
the second Giles by this time I was
really hungry put a spoon into this bowl
I pulls out like I have a shitty either
time or weekend I was like heart of not
feeling ill anyway I was introduced to
last year and just launched it and let's
just say guy grabs and just started
sucking he heads off it [__] you just
play please yeah because I think they in
Tainan these every part of the life eat
everything yeah yeah yeah I didn't
Michele initially you know but you find
yourself force and it sound you know you
when you've got no money and you've got
no friends and there's no one out there
yet you know you've only got one choice
and you've got to eat how we do it and
we're all those guys are in it because
we see it like they look like me and
[__] these guys like they
taught news all over their faces they're
not the biggest guys but there's so many
of them yeah I mean they're surrounding
you constantly pushing you and getting
into you and yo you still one-on-one
fight even though you're a hard guy
because of them had been in the boxing
arena and I had a few times that was
similar with cha sujin
when I got in there it was like these
are these are these are the gang you
know these are collectively as a unit
together they're gonna have kind of and
that was it was it was flying and what
was boring it was the stories I thought
it was soul well I mean about these guys
before I met them okay but I mean it was
like these are the hiv-infected shaman
eyes you know they've got no life you
know Diwali
you don't value your life one of the
threats that were made were to inject
people with hair choice yeah wasn't it
amazing you know did battles you know
that was a cleverly made into syringes
and it fill er up with blood a weekly
you know it would be infected
JV I'd seen a senile happen a few times
that witnessed the rape you know as
witness to murder within within a week
of being in a prison in Bangkok and it
was the most frightening experience you
know and I'm you know I don't witness
matters every day a lot of regularly
cadence
oh yeah just Sheena getting killed it
shouldn't happen you know what you never
buy this stuff but you never actually
you know this Psalm I said when you [__]
yes what's up this girl got to do yeah
it was this gang and it was a young kid
about 25 it was a drug deal that went
wrong things over for LeSean it all is
his shot and he chased him and I seen
him run on past and I'm standing there
and the guy ran out with a share crack
them across the face he fell to the
floor and they should have a kid but
standing behind a man maybe she was
slowly
stabbing him just like it was Jeff shots
you know in the neck yeah it was cold it
was calculated it wasn't done in a
frenzy demand it was just like and the
screams every scream was [__] thief
and it was like that all come from each
course not I mean come from somewhere
deep down it was like wow it was in your
main place out it was like whoa and it
was like the way this team was it was
all his slow motion and I was watching
it as it was happening like this that
feeling like of Gilson and not being
able to intervene and then knowing that
if you did it's not even your problem
but at the scene sound was just as fans
fixed it was like I was just watching it
as a human we're taught to try and stick
up for each other and look after people
who are vulnerable and all of that but
like in that scenario you've got a
[__] sit on and let this [__] play
out because you your next basically if
you do anything in it I already got
Michelle Vince's ass at this time you
know it was the shame gang that was yeah
threatening me and so she had to meet
it's a threats of violence and the
fingers across her throat and rape and
the old Molly your name
that's a beg the mission at each that
used to visitors to help a dish yes I
was and after after she and our fourth
[__] it [__] right I don't pay the
Jets mom
hey and I paid that set how'd you get
into debt
flee drugs getting jokes without having
any money and promising to pay them
right by the end of the month
when we got this little mm bias off the
prisoners applause and it's that's for
like ten thousand but by this time what
I mean I was given at me plot C tablets
it was given to me vitamins everything
not given the clothes off me back at
Shelby show you know you can have
everything you know it was him it was
just like I hadn't known I was not quite
a doctor system it was just a lonely
stuff of you if you want to know what
loneliness feels like [__] in the shell
with eighty people might [__] in the
shell with eighty people no one can
speak speak English yet you can't
explain or Express how you feel and you
know cuz I felt really [__] ants I'm a
human being I'm a man you know and I
don't wanna a
afterimage of like for super mama I was
scared and I'm flailing little boy you
know it was only the lazy boy thought I
was [__] in between and I was sharing
between a lady boy called Tiffany and a
guy that I died this is me finished nice
enough for Michelle the guide side right
the night before you just left been left
just being left there for two days age
and howdy died you know
no idea didn't didn't have to answer to
ask you just the one who's depicted
where you wake up and you're right next
to him yeah it's already dirty
you're almost leaning on him like you're
sleeping almost yeah like you're you
roll over and it's right there because
I'm still I've still got these dog
started look back so I'm still
intoxicated and still under the
influence you know this lady boy
symphony with this sharp no money no
honey she's I like your blue a solid I
remember saying I love your blue eye you
know that you're Brad Pitt I was
thinking you know for her like the brown
yeah yeah bit paranoid about the same so
I feel a bit flattered really
absolutely I mean when you're feeling
lonely even that would probably be like
better than nothing at any level of
affection and yeah just someone being
nice to you well she was like the
humanist name but those experiences
early like
arms and legs like a much graver focus
like where's the bad Sonali my F going
in there really that's gotta be like
bombs waiting yeah or somewhere in the
UK like you're bad yeah I got a pillow
and maybe an Xbox does it CVG play there
you know the [__] non but I mean is
floor look ahead yeah and you gotta
[__] bug role as a pillow and it's so
small as well in this there's no many
men in there that they they haven't that
could look the Richard yeah was when
they sleep and that was weird I was like
they're literally like hooking each
other like in like file its [__]
balls on your head and [__] legs
wrapped around you at an arm's you we
can open your like each one focused on
kiss me a lot I mean it's that close you
must've been pretty sleep-deprived then
it's it's how much could you sleep like
cuz at the same time not only that but
you're worried about the threat in the
cell anyway of something happening you
must have slept the one eye open almost
the charge of anybody passive raise it
right you know when a consume or for a
see you could have to shoot staff
members garden a thousand inmates right
and they'd be like they would for they
would not do not they wouldn't you
wouldn't seen alright it's not like in
the UK we le was buying it up kicking
off button shoots huge and and they did
rule reduced so at man o'clock every
night I wish to the blog you'd have to
be silenced
you did the whistle you couldn't speak
after nine o'clock so the next day eight
o'clock before that eight o'clock did
twice as well every 12 I was doing after
the national anthem to say national
anthem you have to stand up like that I
only have standards to attention while
the flag was gone
da-da-da-da-da-da-da
[__] simian can go like that for years
every day I'd have to stand there but I
was like this is not a pleasure on the
water yeah 8:00 a.m. and then a CAPM it
after stands up Michelle try a national
anthem nine o'clock to wish a blog no
one could saw lights it'd be on it'd be
like this no [__] like they would
switch it off you'd expect it to be dark
and gloomy I'm really are staying them
deep Connolly waterfall yeah yeah right
do you have a guy's [__] at the end of
the shell on suicide watch
shaking shift every hour because it was
against the rules to kill yourself I was
one of the readouts ten rules every morn
one of them was you can't kill yourself
I'll sign up by a pair of shoelaces of
this I guide my why why they for him
really [__] long I was she pressed
like there was none left and I did now
lost a will sell 11 and he and he was
gone he was old me a little on of Don's
he said because what'll happen is
collectively as it as a shell will be
punished this is what the rules are and
when we get punished we get punished and
that that was like probably one of the
most selfless acts of like not doing it
you know and I've not like you shared so
much swords here where that was in
broken English him whether it was inside
see the way he was kind of you know his
body language is enough and then I got
the lay in sigh because did we give me
all the wrong medication right you know
so I learned to speak science to
understand there that was a big mistake
because then able to Shana Bobby yeah
you know what I was like here war that
caused a lot of reaction no a lot of
violence a lot of that a lot got beaten
up a lot because you know of course you
know I'm not a Venetian never get past
it and I'll do it again a pass it was
never well and so on it was like it was
like a creeper doom and she stood Sonya
lastly was only like this this officer
position you like the Oscars Ella or you
this prison should get your [__]
together month for canal is it don't you
on the boxing scene because you're gonna
end up set these will never fight you
want to one of you wanna fight someone
and so on you get in that ring and if
they do Nakata a.m.
Candace would give me a bit of attention
and I'll understand you speak pretty
good English as well so it was nice to
convey hmm you know and get a message
conveyed to me from from shamanic head
in a way proclaim you're lonely like
that then anyone saying anything just
feels like yeah yeah I'm you know a few
words at that point just makes all the
difference I suppose so yeah yeah and
and then obviously I thought they had a
boxing yeah in a [__] prison door
yeah stranger glad he good-looking one
as well look nice so yeah so you you
finally get to do that after they let
you in there yeah and you learn how to
do this this is where you in the movie
you learn my tie for the first time
properly and you already led a daughter
delaying quite a lot of at this says you
thinking what our desired actor wants us
to dr the film was there was like three
fights mmm you know and this is how we
describe this to be the face one it's
very angry and you [__] just like
this there's no rolls by and you're
going at it you know hell-for-leather
the second one you sure to got a little
bit more skillful I think you've lanes
what you've joined the team it shows you
a bit more direction the tears when
you've mastered the art of it in a sense
because but wanna point you them with
the best of the best and in this one
let's just ER and then the style
attention you know are not that in a
feeling of kind of peace you know you
know you it's it's it's not like follow
sound and visual violence in that way
it's more control than you've developed
you're a martial artist you know martial
artist however for me you know artists
Lynch scrapyard mousse I like his shared
I never went to schools I never once a
silly it's a proper training camps where
the deal or I just I was layin in cod4
from sports pure like Daisy Thrace yeah
and it in back that way so when you went
to prison was were they training you yet
more properly back yeah there was a guy
called hmm sage I [__] amazing I'd
love to see him again also got Eames
Diaz yeah you know he was like he took
me under his wing
her first it's played by a guy called
summer camp sing in the film someone
comes saying is here is the only size to
wear a gold medal at the Olympics in
boxing you see the bigger guy of a
trainer yeah yeah he's like a good
character
yeah he's like the undefeated Li welcome
news a champion of Thailand easily
usually he's a legend he's a legend
since Island everyone knows we can slap
him on board so we played the role of
China sighs yeah it was great study it
kind of he brought me in to be his
little world and he [__] me son and he
talks when I was a [__] kid believe
like loosely he normally give me little
morsels of am language knowledge ago
this is what you needed to not only seek
his time on me and that was that that I
felt like a pastor shortened and unified
and I was you I was involved you know I
landed my mod idea you know and you had
an outlet for all the energy inside
again lows of anger laws event stop
seeking drugs because that was a big
problem you know like a share of what
analogy to the ropes you don't [__]
do to cope with them
one thing that really struck me about
the film and obviously with the food
being so bad I mean you know you do a
lot of box and trainers on you probably
still train you need a lot of food to
train how do you end up training boxing
and looking in good shape and being in
good shape when the food is so bad well
that's that's the benefit of being in
the air the boxing team it's called
horn-like put you're done she'll call
home luckily it's him at the sports L
where you get plea religious you know
you get extra food but she's like
sustainable I mean people get visits and
he can have food under then so there's a
lot of [__] and there's a lot of beef
there was a lot of poor there was a lot
of rice a lot of vegetables that they
were bitten so I was like oh no I mean a
so you sustain known enough that I've
run on water
yeah in the camp that I mean you know
out of pipe but it was doing I'm just
constant you didn't have to go by it or
wait like you I've seen you fight over
the water in the movies just to get your
bottle scanned it was just like you know
have you ever this is how it was like
that you got to pace your name coming
out of a football stadium
mmm shocker than it you can't [__]
move you can navigate that's what it was
like just trying to get swim water or go
to sauna I mean because the the film is
there's water throughout the film it's
quite interesting actually like I guess
it's not image
but there is a lot of water in the film
there's there's you I'm just a stream of
water at one point and I think I read a
review where mentioned about the water
and kind of you're constantly showering
or wet or damp or something like that
and weirdly in most films waters about
washing sins away or you know if
someone's just murdered someone they go
to the shower and they said and they cry
but you and your cattle the character
you you could never do that it always
just felt like the water is almost like
a punishment separate to you was it
is it quite what's it like in the prison
it doesn't seem particularly it was
abundance in a sense way there was a
larger but you couldn't drink it yeah no
I mean it was like a trough that's it
it's about as big as this table if this
wears off and you pee around here gonna
be like a pipe so Isis they feel and
look more nice and it'd be like so high
and then you get a little Bowl and he
you'd be showing yourself that we sold
coke was you that three goals show
yourself off three goals you've got this
blue shade for jobs with as well the
only button wouldn't Blake give it the
next day wash it off look me she pays
him but I am you have to wash swag but
it and I get her off again I was just
mad on what I mean I see some [__]
crazy things I remember I was that
transitions sort of Pleasant and the way
was being a for a couple used by ASAP
and every morning you'd be a little
little hot Wars the thing with it very
clearly you know you know for the coffee
I'd be a cube a infinite I miss this
this this young shy guy come running out
of the office one more HIV and be all
I'm see cases and you stabbed himself
with this ice pick it was making his
chance to blow the scare and everywhere
and then the other something she'll
fastest it was it was fun as you saw was
this like that because the guys will
also handle body blade or call enemies
easy for concern he you know he's gonna
give a shot name everyone wait you know
lot and what did the jam and the
commotion and okay the fish forth back
ends of my others I guess your mop water
uh shapes like well while all those like
five diversion
I was like coffee coffee while he's
doing that you're in the corner going
tell us what about a bit well yeah just
straight with the law should know what
should i was grave yeah but do you wanna
watch it fall on it past you Sam you
know obviously it's a after it's
finished be coffee yeah but yeah that's
just our became you know it was a few
foreigners in there you've watched a
really in a big way I mean shoot on
saucepan lids and just just oh she's was
it quite a mixed thing because in the
film obviously you're the only white guy
in there was it yeah it was like three
on the different Nationals in so I had a
pleasure for twenty thousand inmates
well you get occluded you know and I got
put in a block where there was no photo
illusion yeah because of the way would
be Haven I couldn't communicate and
relate with the foreigners because it's
just for these cannot against me no
Iranian is a lot of Iraqis there was a
lot of Africans that I mean they they
they kinda the ones that fed yeah it was
like the size used to call our food to
you and so when the Africans had come
runnin through with the trough lay the
robe you don't know the size of it
wow I mean like Bangor I and then they
get the big portion and you gonna be
waiting and all a sickly peak on
powerful of you a war so but I'm like a
flying cat us any any what do you want
by get away get away
what's going on right what the [__]
[__] get that way I'm on I'm at nothing
like this is these it's what's these I
must say really difficult it's a by this
you can often right let's take it all of
the syllabus yeah it's just the food
that we got free yeah twice a day yeah
we got a choice day but everyone was in
for the pyranose people be shelling
medication and the coolest she was
stamps in cash stamps the king jet was a
big thing if you understand with the
Kings as on you could you know our
policy shot of Zola there was a lot of
that going on what are the most powerful
parts of the movie for me was when they
sort of pin you down and you're not sure
what's going on like
oh you know it was very unsightly driven
scene like you're like [__] oh
they're gonna kill him yeah hmm then
they pin you down and then they pin
another guy to the wall and they rape
them and meet you watching
you said you'd actually seen ribs before
I mean how do you get over something
like that and why is it like during that
time where you're just trying to [__]
get through it I just buried me Edouard
Roche that's all that's our go through
that's how I dealt with problems she was
a junior - any feeling any force because
a good enclosure like the pleasant you
know answer cannot be in reality or a
fantasy and it was just I couldn't I
couldn't be in the reality at all so
that was our butt out don't get me wrong
when I came back I have to deal with all
I saw me over the set here the gone a
lot of talking to people oh yeah you
know I'm about sort of a lot of other
people as well and as you leave because
you know what about the ones with prison
and I was sad explained see this
psychotherapist he pulls out of [__]
pocket cards starts a plane and with me
really
it makes us just being you know how're
you feeling
I don't [__] know but I know what I'm
thinking I mean just you know as always
go of paranoids I was laying I was
really sure misha's and very passive and
it was yeah I felt like a tourist him
you don't conceive when I love the pack
in the UK and I was [__] now it's
changed me names he use of muhammad's
while I was in Thailand writes it for
the pillow foods got your stage pays all
these debts was in there all these drugs
had gone and I couldn't score drugs
anymore didn't wanna score drugs anymore
I don't know about that way in life our
thoughts on her face the [__] Zahia
what I mean I was walking around for
weeks
you know normally eaten please and food
nor visits and these Muslims really
named this wonderful later table like
this you know imagine it just oh like a
big wonderful spray of every in Normandy
for those of him those with loads of
different issues and I was just walk
past that he's a walking a Rayleigh
ambitions jealous you know like the
hunger
really puncture a really killing me her
name
blossom looked at me shed my friend
would you like to join us after ask me
sir Aisha [__] shots on button price
is it before we before we eat will have
to play okay yeah no no no matter I'll
be played like this which is I shall
play anyway you want me near to him
even I enjoy the Hannibal I could show
you to the ass I'm gonna mean on filming
stomach and I aim sense myself come back
somebody but ok mmm my friend up only
only too much number to come here
you are welcome today but you know so
forth was my brother shot cut off came
back the next able to [__] on I'm a
school cap on shot a she said my name is
Yousef Mohammed I was gonna say Mohammed
Ali because that's really [__] bother
me ok suppose the juiciest Muhammad
never pastor than I let it was grace it
is okay use of you join us now you have
to do wish I had that I should do halal
Aloha she - hum-hum but also loan on it
might be Mohammed so to do this like I
says she P I inserted the Shahada with
them and then I go for the gym and
wrestling alibis I'm gonna go through
the Quran or dinner just to Jenna but
then he moved me into shell and I'm
playing five hours a day to wake me up
it's a facade yeah rush you know like
blacks walking got a bit too far now
they've moved me into a Shelia you
beaten Muslims up yeah now you're now
you're sitting to sell praying five
times a day
yeah but then I believe I had actually
believes it was a Muslim right
that went on for like a year were you I
were you're actually spiritual in that
time do you think you think it did help
you that didn't didn't use dogging I
didn't what I want to put what about it
what I realized is like again because
the boxing scene with move Ramon please
you know that's a you know ice to leave
that present in the end and comes up
it's a Bangkok Dharam collectively
as a unit I needed support mmm I used to
say to them ask questions to see you
know cause of labor close minded she's
Amish place Muslim gay Lorelai you know
you blowing up people and what's it all
about with the backpacks right why are
you doing that because I had no insight
and they obviously didn't see it that
way he said look this is what a dish you
know Billy when we see us a lamp over
there home module alhamdulillah it means
you're a bro there no way I was gonna
come see you you're a friend I said so
what's all this chitchat then you know
jihad is like a fight within the
conflict that you go what these
extremists and fundamentalist they're
not real like to sit down on free on
Muslims so can i assassin Cigar
Aficionado an eruption and they were
really just two cycles moving
númenóreans on a human level on a human
level of just like Oh Shiva kind and
compassionate understanding they didn't
want any violence theater only forcing
over to feed on me just a means to keep
the engine room alive name to survive
you know DT noob this is a new bill we'd
be no idiot it's okay your Possible's it
was better like Julie Wendy wanted to
get me [__] for skiing chopped off by
one of his mates yeah we've heard things
in alchemy sure she's Yuki this year it
sounds like you had a quite positive
experience there though
yeah let's say they brought I became
travel broadens the mind Brian it was it
was beautiful in this chance where I
washing well the judgments I had thought
me a little bit more now I can't do call
it a bit more elevated with the in
selective at all okay yes all a new
store for name you know they're quite
nice and I left and that was card at the
end every sentence clean going on a
after five years of being in the country
you allowed back to the UK one yeah yeah
yeah [__] did you have to finish the
sentence in the UK yeah as a monsoon was
weird to do how did that feel
it was like it was March today at the
fancy fairs 2000s and you flew me back
she plays an officer's [__] next to me
on a plane on a PA I mean it was like 40
degrees in silent and Bangkok was on
fire it was like it was like a red red
red and yellow share party going up
people sharing the shitty up on fire it
was all over the news
flights were getting stopped we fly got
stopped two days before but never one of
these islands you know what I mean
the airport was surrounded by like like
like protesters and having nothing me
like you just the way they were on stuff
hey and I guess we flies in into the UK
Ashlee's and cold I mean I could put on
a shell and I just slept on the floor
this is a bed there I didn't feel
comfortable at all not bad
stays on I flew over all three reach
with me legs wrap around the pipes
because it was that [__] cold and I
was struggling with communicating in
English me English was like mixed with
sight because a 1 port passive tight I
have pubs like some kind of fluids
inside at that stage it's always they've
media English was broken with sight and
then cause I'm from cap cap us at the
tank you know I was one yes yeah yes you
know you know you're living now bill
starting grains in me I'm so awkward
speed yet stands and it's any Q but it's
lay it only be chips and mushy peas and
chicken legs and and then you did these
cockney kids gone [__] cats [__]
chips man family that's [__] [__]
a net what a [__] village sneaking
over there you know then talk about cold
chips and mushy peas this is [__]
great dish
we've seen this a bit of a novelty in
the prison then when you came back yeah
you know it was shame
yeah lots of questions getting asked
people were like he insisted I mean it
was unbelievable you know you couldn't
invent or conjured up a new version I
made what you kind of witness than it
being shipped chapter two and I decided
to write about it it was like Telep you
see for me the calf assertion in writing
kind of
help me aim comes to change with because
I couldn't I could sell you a lot of
souls a long the goals you know what I'm
sorry - story but you're not gonna like
densified because you haven't shared an
experience so when people would ask me
these questions in bonds MIT and they
were like just lookin at me like I was
so I felt like isolated again I'm gonna
put down on paper on a shoulder to this
young female it's CJ you weight them
educating the band since yes school math
next a student my class amazing Johnny
won a four piece of paper of at these
collective experience of that she needs
to make more know what she's [__]
amazing you gonna you can raise a book
you and she encouraged me i sat myself
at a monster nose broken roads and and I
will be there for the sha'ban but the
stuff of being free it was healing you
know like clothes off as well as a
backstory and apocalypse glow up you
know the fresh memories were the ones
that activated the the easiest the name
and the rest is history about album at
the published was how well it's six
months it became an international
bestseller let's make a movie mother for
Thursday 7 that's miss all these actors
you know I'm just a crazy mixed-up kid
from a stupid sound I [__] up his old
life use drugs and uh it's loads of
shitty experience she's wonderful
experience Isabelle up there you know
and I'm wrong about it and people goes
here you know you're in Japan and a
nation you know you feel like a fraud
they look like I'm sure you could
survive it if you didn't fall fight back
he was gone really owe you a long
shorter
no I and I think are the biggest there
this [__] in there just shook
his did what the the bit that really
struck me about was your adaptability
and nothing sort of shows adaptability
more than the relationships you were
building up in there listen and one of
them was with Fame who was was that is
that the real name no I was John in the
book named Shane didn't he yeah to set
the
of a leaderboard and so you get close
with Fame who also works in I guess the
shop there and you selling cigarettes
and those kinda you've been big enough
for those and then you get intimate with
her because I didn't come by the way
yeah yeah yeah I wrote that it didn't
actually know James yes so you had like
a close friendship yeah cuz I read that
that's why I said you get intimate
rather than yeah sure sure yeah and
obviously then it's portrayed
differently in the film mmm why was it
protruded I was gonna ask why is there
artistic
yes detective he wanted to bring a bit
more than some machines away you want
some like you should look built this is
later Baba Rockets visuals violence it's
blood sweat shots whose drugs he said
it's a machine
it's bring you a little bit of closeness
how does he feel like you know what it's
it's you're the director you're at work
you don't think it was right yeah yeah
my mates are gonna see this face away
and fell and then you know what the
[__] question that people ask me is
how much money did you make from this
movie and did you sleep with a fella
with this hitch that's seriously that
questions being on you know I was bored
by other people in by people like a
little bit more not all matters the
relationship with John in in the prision
at the time was one of like him I've
been beaten attracts a nice temperatures
Kosovo clearly again through actions and
my own responsibilities over drugs two
salads all situation or once it soaks
you know couldn't either pain and either
form a scar on your stomach and
everything name and she show me a bit of
understand that compassion and closeness
but I mean Mickey Mouse on healing
you okay this was gorgeous as well as
that lazy boy in a movie [__] you last
year's [__] amazing what I mean she's
just a lovely person and I say is she
because whether she's understanding or
not she's just a woman but I mean she's
got all those feminine kind of qualities
and as I'm access she was amazing in the
nephilim name but yet it was shame
you couldn't imagine she in a prison
full of sweaty man and then you've got
this [__] you know and it'd be on a
case because of just being Pete you know
being Shella gated from your protection
at the time you have put on longer
innocence I mean for a month if
punishments a I'll have a short [__]
next year melena Chanel mmm
letting me a lot take some kind of
perfume and coconut oil and making an
effort with himself
yeah and a little fun and then blow at
any of the year before
well I don't fancy you know I was like
I'm not a sedation and then I thought my
biggest fear the age for a living look
at this fella yeah I rang this anymore
and said I'm not coming back it's me and
John just two others but it was just it
was it was never like it was never like
a sexual kind of range there but was
very intimate in a way become here in
cases mm-hmm but I still feel that still
be filled with that shame if anyone
looks and seeing this cause of that male
muscular only see that we carry him oh
jeez nobody didn't think she got me flu
a lot as well how does it me feel
looking back on that do you still feel
affect look I don't mean you know sexual
affection but affection towards people
like that like you feel any affection
towards the people you're in prison wait
yeah I feel like did the fact that the
poorly educated I remember one guy come
to me and I was like the most for him
weirdest question you could ask someone
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh even Superman does he
does he ever go to London I remember you
believe that Superman was real he
believed that all these Marvel
characters before come deal you know I
mean I mean ever had met Malcolm it's
just he or he was just before him really
believed and I was like it's believed
Superman
you know we very real I was like it's
just so like they were really [__]
like no knowledge of any ninety meaning
you have any very naive yeah
so yeah it's got some like him from
feeling sore Ximena sense of like you
know
tosod really it really is because no the
conditions that they in for inaudible I
mean literally people with like no legs
on your blinds in there I can wear them
at guards because that scene at all
there's a kid nearly at the nets I got
on called Cochran and he had the same
penis tattooed on his [__] father
pilot no these are the shy guys you
personalized them and you know because
he was in for me than his parents and
that's a big thing you don't kill your
[__] family and you don't kill him
anyway but you think that the same don't
you didn't get that no literally pull
him you know anything said Pope and you
know you know there was a guy that got
shot by the police and he lost useful
horizon he was walking around with a
stick and norm was helping him and you
know there was another guy who lost his
legs and it was on a little piece of
woods with a wheel on it pulling himself
or the hands on his hands
this is in the prison like ICC within a
shitty you know and not everyone was
friends over the childhood you gotta be
seen some manage and get by you with me
it was like the because Siobhan I'm sure
mouth but like his a laser shock to the
system so yeah the Shaun the Sheep
Thailand just generally to me is bizarre
like that some of that that I have more
places entire line just say like
documentaries well I'm like that Lord
[__] me up let alone the prison Meili
yeah weird yeah I can say why you'd be
drawn there for the adventure you come
back you're in England now you've got
people offering new movie deals for this
book that's got the top of the charts
you take it you setting me on the text
message you were like something happened
people asking you how much money you got
paid and all that you said you had an
issue yeah what was the issue
I was Jame I was Mitchell as always a
shabby in the industry I had no way
agents at this this dish this story this
book and enough that they store and you
know the refused to see me
you know the dispositions you know kept
calm about my speaks of the maladies
down and you know the managers
eventually said sit you know we'll
Safety's off yet or maybe even like it
will be insouciant she's the local
company in Liverpool and three months
later the
de for me so we need to sit down I'm
thinking okay it's okay mentally expose
the both of written that's only being
published in silent at the moment and
get a chunk analyzer on it so we can get
some sales and we want to make a [__]
movie a feature and I was like dude and
then he started coming out with all
these names Charlie Hunnam and Jason's
to happen but sad thing is you wanna
show up everyone would am it generous to
you it's just how you cast anyway me him
but the likes of a and then I was like
who is so they when I seed all the
contracts getting shine I said like I
need an agent even though those Scouts
even stated together well yeah but no
it's a talkie talk whales got
manipulated into shine on a concept and
reducing me fee because he told me that
everyone else should reduce their fate
so the movies go ahead but the neighbors
have perished but they these are the
producers distraught about certain about
just have a pretty clearly she told me
what happens no one introduced a fee and
they had to fill it so I had the lowest
kind of become a percentage of out of
everyone I mean 1.5 percent said it was
ridiculous you know it's never gonna be
a big amazing movie making millions it's
almost like Mamma Mia don't not like
that but you know it was my life it was
my journey which might blood my sweat
and my season I haven't even put into it
yeah just dismissed so you know I
thought like laws of conservation
disagreements and I'm not like here it's
a put thumbs around ago this is one of
this this used to the industry another
me name I was just laying a lesson it's
not the first time I've heard
unfortunately we had Nick Yaris who did
a fear of 13 on Netflix he did 23 years
on death row for a crime he didn't
commit
and he else he said the same thing about
the guys who made his movie as well
she's terrible because it's I think
that's the industry though they see more
like you come in anything he won't
understand what's going on here until
it's too late
exploitation well I was being played
phone calls on pressure they say no perk
a fish right with with with documents
sorted lines needs a sandwich you know
you know I need to manipulate the fact
that to go you know you know he's only
got a couple of days and if these are
sad we will be able to get the movie
made her name so the shiet lot of me in
a shines and it you know of got next to
Martin really be proud of the story the
way it's told but and plowed the
distorted away sold a lot of desire
after year 60 review on a howl of the
character Joe Cole he's a [__] amazing
friend him the rice is Jonathan H being
a get on bail with him the Liverpool
Fame I kind of focused on them
I swear and I've never shared this but I
you know I love [__] drawings what I
mean the way they kind of like exploited
me and it's you know a nice thanks and
change see me when I found out I found
out and available to Norwich Alastair we
said well yeah over here
it was old what'll happen is when
consultation nation dish happened and
then connected in China we will cover
the costs never did never Tate and
that's just our ace so being left in but
you know what I'm richer in in life you
know do a lot in the community today him
Norma involved but a pro that he's got
autism and he's beautiful
you know he's a you know people say oh
he suffers with ulcers and he doesn't
he's blessed with innocence he's lovely
he's a mission for years she's just been
anyway he's 40 years old I mean issues
to love and care and like gentle giants
I hate dismiss them do you mean like you
just weren't aware of like how good of a
thing you could have them yeah
as his misters you know them I mean
phone was more important than be family
mmm-hmm not I mean what kind of like
insurance dinner on Instagram was more
important than me gone yeah
this is my brother we okay look yeah
yeah I missed I was you know give us
five minutes and he piece won't tell me
about his day and I think in five months
you know in a minute and then I weigh in
as a you know called week in a month a
few years later it go like that nothing
me
be shittin in you know it's only been
recently the last six months worth of
develop this relationship with a man
i'ma say consider it that it's on the
boxing club it's it's it's it's an
all-inclusive hope kids with autism you
know we're involving the whole community
you know and I volunteer there every
weekend I've done it without fail and he
comes along
now his confidence she's like you know
he's very consoling no you know he's a
PC right and he comes out with a speech
at the end of the the end the body is a
PC in my you know and it was useful a
yes he's just do love him in there I
mean he could not you could not I put a
post on dude your aunt's Reza did as a
puppy I'll be probably playing at am
because great shot my name is Betty I
mean the relationship I observe is very
different from the relationship he has
moved a bit more it was different
surname he was saying it was the best
out in the world and he said you know
it's visuals it because you were sure
our woman and upholster day and it
reached also like a course of a million
views within two days I was like I can't
even get [__] 20 likes on a forum not
a smile on of me but like that just
proved you know III had a that say was
really emotional it was me that better
you know brings your poor lad orphans
like you know so k to feel not okay and
to be human because I haven't got that I
struggle to to to share the T in me and
I don't know what it is I'm us from
[__] emotionally blocks you and I
swallow a you know I'll do it I've been
doing a foolish podcast through the
walls it I push it down instead of like
because of that applies and that ego and
the feel of being short yeah you know
it's it's him it's okay you crying there
in the film yeah it was is that true
that you cried in prison because I can't
reward him it is that makes you cry but
you it was a lesser of me that yeah okay
so he's letter of your father
yeah and then it was that a real moment
yeah there was a real moment the only
thing that never happened her name you
know the director
cents miss your father comes to visit
when you feel inflation event no orthros
Kanaskie
yeah and I got the end that's the end
you yeah
please deducted yeah yeah sure but the
ironic kind of thing was a meets outside
the concerts you use before and be able
in the process of doing this Shalom you
know six doesn't see there's nothing
overnight you know all that stuff the
producers did you know what here we know
in and I got diagnosed with cancer
whilst I was on chefs who had spoken on
th stage a non-hodgkins lymphoma that
she really mean that was cheering me up
abdomen the tire that they said you know
before and we know we know we could you
know would you play your father and I
was like you know and he said if you if
you were your father what would you say
to your son to put yourself as in your
father's shoes this is this young actor
Joe Cole is coming towards you he's done
a character study on me knows exactly
the feelings of being called that's been
going on about it a name remember him
standing there at five o'clock in the
morning the last Sheen to be shot in the
Philippines and his prisoners should be
and him be that me being him me and a
filled me shelf I thought I couldn't
even mustard also wanted to shade also
was of the che SEMA show mother love you
that was all I ever wanted nah
didn't want money postal orders or or
any food or she stopped just just those
steel always you know I love you and I
couldn't even bring me shelves to say
that and I'm standing there and I was
looking at this young actor and it was
like I was picture than it that it is to
be don't eat sushi inning
you know that's it that visually isn't
enough none of me in the name that's how
it ended
it was very less as more something I
think they nailed that yeah it was
perfect that we you didn't see anything
because it sort of the way the whole
movie had gone was yeah
like I said at the start you gave the
audience respect that you know they're
gonna get this they don't need to know
every single thing about you as a person
they're gonna learn that throughout it
and not having any words I thought was
brilliant
yeah got the thing that all went on life
goes on and
life didn't go on did you when you
obviously because if the tumultuous
relationship with your dad how did you
feel when you knew he passed away
because you spent so much oh yeah isn't
away from your family the last 10 years
of his life because I've been released
by they say if it was a belt over the
relationship but I'm just quite quite
flattered but it was yeah i could see
how we'll all really care me while she
was glad kids he would quite difference
you know aim he never spoke about his
problems you never never knew not
livadas past each meets as all his life
and they never knew not about him
name you never told me anything but i
knew that through family members that he
had his demons to deal with name you
know he stopped drinking for the last
four years of his life but wouldn't she
help all and he therapy or at chalks
running he just shot his little do you
put his pants on be mad at left him you
never mess anyone else you know a name
we all elders and when he passed away
you know that was most loving care and
you know thing we could do is be there
as a family and regardless of the shitty
polish flu you know just to show them
that he was lost when he did pass away
and he was him he was you know and he
looked at me I can't explain it
it's like an eyes locked right it was
just silence our eyes locks and it was
the moments where I could she loved pain
shame killed through the years in his
eyes and I saw look away and I remember
like looking away and blinking and I
sees just [__] Cascades that really
that was a moment and then you know he
was gone it was aim and did you say
anything to him at that point I said
I've got a call that was all like a
cloud couldn't yeah I'm for the call now
and that was yeah what I mean because no
matter what I shared I you know it's
like he's gonna be in denial he's gonna
like hearing what words were necessary
well no no no legs in the movies yeah
there's not just not sashay and that's
exactly kind of our felt so in a sense
yeah just that she's plot that often
really that's probably our felt button
path down yeah
must be weird for your family to watch
the film because now it's been made into
a film it's almost cast as a bit of a
success story it's you know what I mean
you watch it and it's quite firm ative
in the end you've gone through a lot of
struggle but what got you there was a
really hard painful life but it's been
portrayed in quite not a heroic way
obviously you know it's held bare as a
film how do you think your family feel
about watching their son go through that
and like you know your mom and me mum
files it really difficult so obviously
you know she's the closest thing to me
in me blood ester did you sleep with a
fellow premiere watching it and
everyone's watching it with you and
you're like I didn't do nothing either
you Airedale I was all chef name yeah
maybe this is daddy brother they didn't
even ask me ask me Mom yeah for the
album you never fought go sleep with
that fella did he don't like me well
yeah seems like you quite emotionally
sort of you've dealt with it yeah yeah
but believe me I've there's no way and
there's no nightmares or you know it's
acceptance it's it's like Shep dance it
out I was being automation I'm really
quite I'd like to be honest somebody's
really quiet not shocking but like
surprising because obviously we've had
people who've been in prison on the
podcast before and you always get the
sort of sense of something sort of
remaining with them from those days so
I'm sad I just think it's just it is
life Col John melodia forever it's quite
short people think it's long don't put
it in a blink of an eye it's gone what I
mean decades passed by you know and you
know we're not presidency and out on
welcome body and on what's going on with
our families they're my mission I was
not I mean asleep they go John Lennon
said that life is what pushes you by
when you're looking to shorten else yeah
I've already got two questions left
I was late a lot of notes battlefield I
just was in it's ironic because you've
actually made a movie about your life
book
lots happened since the movie
since the time period in the movie
looking back in your life what would be
that halfway point now if you were to
make the movie now because I feel like
what everyone's got that moment and
yours was our guest going to the present
in the movie but everyone's got that
moment that they look back that was the
point where I just stopped becoming the
real me that was the turning point is it
still going to prison but that in
Thailand is that the chain of poo-poo
shame no one that I don't understand
enough addiction and that it's like
having a belly full of drugs and a head
full of recovery and no one that was a
way out there was a better way of living
so every time I used it was really
uncomfortable it was like he wasn't the
[__] shame anymore the drugs like
it's late as that song and you know the
dogs don't wait anything new to watch it
as usually I just mean that she must
knowledge so much awareness sure to
understand that I know that like the
trucks when we can aim that also was
doing was like just becoming a [__]
zombie and like what I mean so yeah it
was like there was a cliche you know you
usually will never be the same you know
used to cause of these digital recovery
meetings and it's a to me build you know
your usual I'll never be ashamed once
you better taste the dish
oh yeah Dolly's one of it and then it's
like it's like reading the sign on a
pack of cigarettes in it
these [__] seriously cause your lamp
you still smoke them what I mean
but when well it's hard to take it was
like yeah for canal it's not the same
what I mean so I the center point was
probably getting to that rehab years ago
mm-hmm the problem was not dealing with
the emotional thinking getting clean was
enough I'm not dealing with all year the
straw men have grown up and not dealing
with what caused you to wanna yeah do
you most
yeah the emotional upheaval yeah just
thinking yeah clean let's you be
grateful that no just anyway Wow
I've got one more left if you haven't
got if you don't care that yeah all
right how would you like to be
remembered
oh what a lie CB remembers yeah so no a
minute yeah that's quite a lot it's
quite a deep question nothing but like
the people of okay you know what right
I'd like to be remembered as a guy that
can inspire others change and motivate
themselves within their own mental
health and develop it's like well you
know it's it's [__] today we've got
one life and we live it and it's don't
worry about soo much in the past you
know don't focus on what's what's Nadia
I'm a man up stays now where I've gone
done broke whatever Ian you know we a
good luck yeah I'm in the corridor if
you know what I mean once almost in
another closes and I'm stuck in the
Corazon and I don't like being in a
corridor sunshine because I don't know
it's you know it's quite Zak so
sometimes you feel like I'm in the
corridor of life aim and I'm a place
walk not saw because it all what's
happenin and that's what I need I think
it's just a boss having like courage
just to go yeah well through that what
will be will be so yeah that's probably
the most inspiring thing you could think
of it's been a pleasure up me I thought
really fascinating I mean do this again
yeah yeah you've got another book coming
out obviously air so you need to come
back and promote anyway but for people
who haven't i'm not read the book the
movie was photos really immersive
incredible for movies of sky to the sky
amazon yeah and it's the movie is so
worth it and that comes from someone who
watches a lot of films we both watch a
lot of films it's one of the best films
I've seen in years so this year
what's amazing yeah you're on social
media or like in the link in the
description below if everyone's enjoyed
this podcast make sure hit the like
button subscribe thanks for watching and
we'll see you later